qu'est ce que vous pensez de cyril
hanouna
je pense que siri n'est complètement
givrée je pense que c'est le roi de la
déconne comme on n'a jamais vu mais
qu'est ce que vous voulez je laime et
votre soeur qu'est ce qu'elle en pense
très addictif et d'insérer les plus
célèbres l'amour est toutes les deux
cyril bas c'est un bon gars c'est un bon
vivant c'est un ambianceur toujours la
patate il adore sourire c'est un grand
monsieur voilà et votre frère qu'est ce
qu'ils en pensent à pareille heure
délire à tous les délires voilà elle
nous fait marrer on est là tranquille
quoi c'est mon frangin pardon cyril
hanouna connais pas cyril hanouna oui
c'est un danseur peut-être un écrivain
ah oui un écrivain parce que lire s'est
refusé de mourir et votre frère ils en
pensent quoi bon grosso modo parcours
savalas match et ça passe ça passe
cyril avait coûté gens pensent pas du
bien ça fait deux ans qu'ils me dois
2000 euros deux ans dit oui je suis sur
un gros coup je vais te rends pas je te
payer et rembourser
j'en ai marre je veux mon oreille et
votre frère il en pense quoi de deux
mille balles j'en suis le 2000 balle ça
se fait ça
qu'est ce que vous pensez de série là
bas je l'aimais beaucoup maintenant je
suis un peu déçu ça fait longtemps que
je n'ai pas vue à poil
avant ils montraient beaucoup ses fesses
et votre frère qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensent
sovo d'eau pareils sont bull nous manque
qu'est ce que vous pensez de serrer la
main par battre c'est un bon pote mais
voilà ça moi moi je l'appelle à saouler
déjà et cet été devait m'emmener en
vacances aux baléares et m'emmener à
roubaix et vous de faire ils en pensent
quoi à montfrin faut lui poser la
question des etats-unis à rabat